nel corso degli ultimi 25 anni ho
impiegato la maggior parte del tempo a
leggere e scrivere storie o a immaginare
di scriverne una e quello che faccio
anzi se vi devo dire la verità credo sia
l'unica cosa che io sia davvero in grado
di fare perciò prima di tutto lasciate
che vi racconti una storia la storia che
sto per raccontarvi non ha a che fare
direttamente con me nel senso che non è
il racconto di un momento della mia vita
è solo una storia che un giorno ho
sentito e che mi sembra importante
restituire e condividere oggi con voi
potrei intitolarla il serpente
comincia così è una mattina d'estate è
un bambino è in vacanza con i suoi
genitori in una casa in campagna
il bambino si sveglia prima dei suoi e
decide di uscire in giardino a giocare
passa un po di tempo i suoi non si
svegliano la casa e silenziosa troppo
silenziosa nessuno lo chiama per la
colazione
nessuno si preoccupa di quello che lui
sta facendo e perciò il bambino decide
che i suoi hanno dormito abbastanza che
ha tutto il diritto di andare a
svegliarli così torna verso la casa ea
quel punto scopre che i suoi genitori
hanno chiuso a chiave la porta
d'ingresso
la porta è chiusa a chiave
bus e nessuno viene ad aprirgli e così
chiama suo padre sua madre ed
all'interno della casa
suo padre risponde con voce affannata
resta fuori a giocare capite in quel
momento il bambino vuole davvero entrare
in casa anzi non c'è niente al mondo che
voglia di più perciò continua a bussare
ea chiamare fatemi entrare dice aspetta
ancora un attimo risponde il padre con
voce sempre più affannata no fatemi
entrare ancora un secondo
e allora il bambino disperato in paura
perché non capisce quello che sta
succedendo
all'improvviso grida ma c'è un grosso
serpente qui fuori
passano pochi secondi la porta si apre
il padre esce di casa e impugna una
vanga che se ne stava lì appoggiata al
muro dove gli chiede e il bambino indica
un punto in fondo al prato dove c'è un
mucchio di pietre
la dice e così il padre il bambino si
incamminano insieme lungo quel prato
verso quel mucchio di pietre e quanto è
grande e chiede suo padre molto grande
dice bambino e di che colore nero
risponde il bambino e delle strisce
erano verdi la descrizione sembra
impressionare parecchio suo padre e
perciò il bambino aggiunge un altro
dettaglio e altre strisce erano gialle
capite è felice perché non solo suo
padre ha aperto la porta finalmente ma
adesso stanno camminando insieme lungo
quel prato armati di vanga per andare ad
uccidere il serpente
perciò in preda a quella strana felicità
a quella specie di euforia il bambino
aggiunge ancora un dettaglio un
dettaglio di troppo ea due grosse teste
ecco questa è una cosa che un buon
narratore non dovrebbe mai fare in quel
momento il padre si ferma guarda il
bambino è ovviamente capisce che si è
trattato di una bugia potrebbe sgridarlo
in effetti avrebbe ragione non si
raccontano le bugie no e lui si è
spaventato inutilmente
se uno dei miei figli facesse una cosa
del genere credo anzi temo che lo sgrida
ray e perciò la storia finisce così in
effetti il padre sgrida al bambino per
colpa di quel serpente e cioè di quella
bugia non solo si è spaventato ma anche
interrotto quello che stava facendo
e noi abbiamo capito vero quello che
stava facendo
e così rientrano in casa
il padre arrabbiato il bambino
mortificato e la vita continua e la
storia finita potrebbe sembrarvi una
piccola storia in fondo da un certo
punto di vista lo è ma quello che vorrei
chiedervi adesso è secondo voi che cosa
è successo davvero
si trattava sul serio di una bugia che
senso ha questa storia più in generale
che senso hanno le storie qualche giorno
fa mentre immaginavo questo momento con
quell'inquietudine di cui vi parlavo
prima
e mentre ripensavo a quel bambino ho
cercato di nuovo sul dizionario il
significato del verbo inventare uno
scrittore lavora con le parole non ha
nient'altro che le parole e perciò
incerte lunghe giornate solitarie il
dizionario è uno dei suoi migliori amici
è una vita che potrebbe non sembrare
così tanto affascinante e vista da fuori
in effetti bene inventare deriva dal
latino in venire che significa trovare
inventare qualcosa significa trovare
qualcosa di nuovo e questo lo sappiamo
tutti qual cosa che prima non c'era
in questo senso abbiamo inventato la
ruota l'aratro il mulino a vento il
motore a scoppio
la televisione computer i cellulari ma
inventare significa anche qualcos'altro
secondo il dizionario e qui cito
testualmente significa creare con
l'immaginazione fatti che non hanno
corrispondenza nella realtà per illudere
gli altri o anche illudendo se stessi
in effetti vi sarà capitato almeno una
volta nella vita di dire a qualcuno ma
cosa accidenti ti stai inventando ovvero
sarete sentiti dire beh questa è un
accezione del significato del verbo
inventare con cui non sono d'accordo che
non mi piace che non mi va giù
sarà perché come vi dicevo prima passo
la maggior parte del tempo a leggere
scrivere storie cioè
carne e non ho mai pensato che si
trattasse di illudere qualcuno né
tantomeno me stessa anzi smetterei di
farlo se pensassi che fosse così
per quanto mi riguarda inventare
significa trovare qualcosa che c'è già
dentro di noi è come se c'è qualcosa che
sentiamo confusamente che magari
intuiamo soltanto e poi dargli una forma
di modo che gli altri la vedano ecco
questa forma sono le storie
ecco cosa significa inventare una storia
per me non si tratta di illudere nessuno
né tantomeno di raccontare bugie
una storia è la traduzione di qualcosa
che non può essere spiegato le storie
sono traduzioni la paura del bambino per
esempio che lui non avrebbe saputo
spiegare perché è troppo piccolo e
perché poi come fai a spiegare le certe
cose diventa un serpente ed è quella
forma e cioè quella traduzione
ad aprire la porta che era chiusa a
chiave e quella forma quella traduzione
a spingere il padre il bambino lungo
quel prato insieme l'uno accanto
all'altro armati di vanga per andare a
sconfiggere il mostro è questa la cosa
che mi commuove di più quando ripenso a
quella piccola storia a quel bambino gli
istanti in cui il padre il figlio hanno
camminato insieme lungo quel prato per
andare ad uccidere il serpente i momenti
in cui il padre ha sentito la paura del
figlio
anzi di più l'ha fatta sua e si è armato
per andare a sconfiggere il mostro
pensateci un attimo se il bambino si
fosse limitato a dire ho paura
probabilmente suo padre gli avrebbe
risposto tranquillo non c'è niente di
cui avere paura perché non c'era alcun
pericolo
male no ma allora temo che non avrebbe
aperto la porta e che quel bambino
sarebbe rimasto là fuori da solo
e allora vi chiedo di nuovo che cosa
sono le storie davvero perché leggiamo
romanzi o racconti o guardiamo film o
serie televisive
le storie sono la forma di ciò che
sentiamo tutti ma che difficilmente
riusciamo spiegare e soprattutto le
storie aprono porte santa teresa ha
detto le parole preparano l'anima
all'azione ecco è quello che fanno le
storie le storie ci muovono nel senso
che ci commuovono ci commuovono ci
muovono con qualcun altro ci consentono
di condividere almeno per qualche
istante le paure e le inquietudini di un
altro essere umano
i suoi sogni i suoi desideri le storie
ci spingono fuori dal nostro letargo
dall indifferenza dall'egocentrismo dall
illusione perché questa si è
un'illusione che ciò che conti davvero
sia la nostra esperienza e che le vite
degli altri
beh non ci riguardino e in fondo siano
lontane le storie ci spingono alla
compassione compatire sentire con ed è
grazie alle storie che smettiamo di
chiederci ossessivamente e io chi sono
sempre la stessa vecchia domanda e
incominciamo a domandarci e tu chi sei
e questa parola ad accompagnarmi a
guidarmi tutti i giorni quando mi siedo
alla mia scrivania con passione sentire
con riuscire a sentire quello che sente
un altro essere umano e provare a dargli
una forma sentire
non solo e non tanto capire perché c'è
una differenza tra sentire e capire c'è
una differenza tra sentire e tenersi
informati per esempio tenersi aggiornati
ascoltare le notizie al telegiornale
quello che penso e che tutti noi
camminiamo su un lago ghiacciato che
definiamo realtà la lastra di ghiaccio è
robusta abbastanza da reggerci anche se
spesso scivoliamo e cadiamo e poi
dobbiamo rialzarci in piedi e robusta
abbastanza ma prima o poi si spezzerà
esso solo abbassiamo lo sguardo
riusciamo a intravedere quel che c'è
sotto
e quel che c'è sotto può farci paura
anche se difficilmente riusciamo a
spiegarlo dentro ciascuno di noi c'è
ancora e sempre quel bambino impaurito
che bussa contro una porta chiusa a
chiave sperando che qualcuno gli apra ma
c'è bisogno che qualcuno ci senta e noi
dobbiamo imparare a sentire le vite
degli altri
a sentire non solo a capire ecco le
storie ci preparano a questo ci
insegnano questo fin da quando eravamo
bambini e qualcuno ci racconta vari
favole le storie ci ricordano questo le
storie ci muovono e ci commuovono e così
leggendo un romanzo o guardando un film
o anche semplicemente ascoltando
qualcuno che ci racconta qualcosa che lo
riguarda
ecco noi riusciamo a provare quello che
sente anche solo per un istante e la
vita di un altro essere umano
in quell'istante non importa quanto
lontano nello spazio nel tempo non
importa neppure se reale o immaginario
eco in quell'istante la vita di un altro
essere umano conta quanto la nostra vale
quanto la nostra anzi no vale di più
ovviamente il bambino avrebbe dovuto
aspettare con pazienza che suo padre
aprisse la porta ma se fosse andata così
nessun serpente avrebbe fatto la sua
comparsa nel mondo e il padre il bambino
non si sarebbero ritrovati a camminare
insieme l'uno accanto all'altro lungo
quel prato condividendo la stessa paura
nessuna condivisione solo un padre un
bambino separati da una porta chiusa a
chiave e dal silenzio solo una giornata
come tante altre destinate a svanire e
per di più io non avrei avuto una storia
da raccontarvi nabokov ha detto la
letteratura non è nata al giorno in cui
un ragazzo è sceso di corsa sul fianco
di una collina in seguito da un lupo
gridando al lupo al lupo
la letteratura è nata al giorno in cui
un ragazzo è sceso di corsa sul fianco
di una collina gridando per chissà quale
ragione al lupo al lupo e nessun lupo lo
stava inseguendo
ma al lupo c'è sempre e in fondo noi lo
vediamo
ed è per questo che continuiamo ad amare
le storie a cercarle e per questo che
continuiamo a raccontarle e ad
ascoltarle le storie ci muovono e ci
commuovono quando è nato il mio primo
figlio
ricordo di avere provato una strana
inquietudine
ero felice ovviamente ma ero anche
consapevole della sua fragilità
continuavo a sentire una voce ripetere
dentro di me ora sei vivo sei qui ma
proprio per questo non sarai mai
completamente al sicuro
il punto è che non riuscivo a spiegare
ciò che provavo alle persone che avevo
intorno e che mi amavano e che io amavo
temevo che fra intendessero che
equivocasse rowe che pensassero che
magari io non fossi così felice anzi
anche un pò depresso
per di più mi sembrava sbagliato quello
che stavo provando perciò cercavo di non
pensarci ma sapete
in effetti avevo visto un serpente e
così ho cominciato a scrivere un
racconto per dare una forma a quelli
inquietudine e quando finì quel racconto
e poi venne pubblicato quel serpente si
fece d'un tratto più piccolo più
inoffensivo
non che abbia smesso di esistere ma
sapevo che non mi avrebbe più fatto del
male e poi ho ricordato a me stessa una
cosa che non ero da sola perchè
qualcun'altro l'aveva visto sotto la
lastra di ghiaccio
magari con un'altra forma non ero da
sola di ciò di cui non possiamo parlare
di ciò che non riusciamo a spiegare
possiamo comunque raccontare una forma
una storia ovviamente lo facciamo tutti
da sempre perché siamo tutti dotati di
immaginazione tutti nessuno escluso
anche qui anche quelli che dicono a noi
o no
come se l'immaginazione fosse un
dettaglio un accessorio una perdita di
tempo una colpa
siamo dotati di immaginazione come siamo
dotati di occhi di orecchie di un cuore
di due polmoni ed è per questo che sono
sicura più che sicura e vorrei gridarlo
tutti i giorni che le storie non
cesseranno mai di esistere che
continueremo a cercarle e che
soprattutto saranno sempre centrali al
centro della nostra esistenza
al centro della nostra vita ovunque noi
andiamo
nonostante quello che ci dicono i dati
di vendita un po sconfortanti dai
romanzi di narrativa la vita è così
breve e la lastra di ghiaccio e sottile
quello che vorrei dirvi è che dovete
sentirvi liberi di inventare serpenti
lo facciamo tutti da sempre e lo faremo
per sempre perché ne abbiamo bisogno e
soprattutto non dovete smettere di
credere ai serpenti che gli altri vi
dicono di avere visto anzi di più dovete
uscire a cercarli con loro
dovete uscire a cercarli non voltate la
testa da un'altra parte
non dite a voi stessi a ho la mia vita
ho i miei problemi o faccende più
urgenti di cui occuparmi faccende
concrete a sono solo storie
solo così imparerete a sentire davvero
ciò che prova un altro essere umano e
credetemi non c'è niente che valga di
più quanto la risposta alla domanda chi
sei
la compassione non è un dettaglio la
compassione non ci rende più deboli ci
rende più forti e ci rende più forti
perché ci dà la misura di quanto conti
la vita di quanto sia misteriosa e non
solo alla nostra
per fortuna la vita di ciascuno di noi
di quanto sia multiforme e variegata
dolorosa e meravigliosa così come le
favole non raccontano favole le storie
non raccontano storie le storie non sono
mai solo storie le storie sono la porta
che ci separa dagli altri
anzi no le storie sono la chiave e sono
ovunque
al centro della nostra esistenza ovunque
noi siamo anche qui oggi
provate a guardarvi intorno guardate chi
avete davanti o alle vostre spalle
guardate chi avete a destra oa sinistra
decine e decine di storie possibili
decine e decine di porte che possono
aprirsi no che devono aprirsi le storie
sono la chiave
basta soltanto continuare ad usarle
grazie
[Applauso]